au club de la presse madame simone veil
a été interrogé aussi à propos de la loi
sur l'interruption de la grossesse
demain l'épiscopat français publie un
livre blanc et une déclaration
solennelle aux catholiques sur cette
question vous savez que la loi votée il
ya cinq ans sera réexaminée comme il
avait été convenu à l'époque au cours de
la session d'automne du parlement
alors en ce qui concerne la natalité le
président de la république a répondu
notre jour très très clairement est vrai
pouvoir devrait donner un exemple au
québec c'est la seule province du canada
où la loi sur l'avortement qui est
applicable dans tout le canada dans tout
le canada n'est pas appliquée et bien
c'est au québec que le taux de natalité
est le plus bas est d'ailleurs en france
on a vu le taux de natalité baisser bien
avant que la loi sur l'avortement soit
soit votée et on a même vu en 1977 une
petite remontée du taux de natalité
je crois vraiment que ça n'a absolument
aucune influence devrait rappeler aussi
entre 1920 et 1940 quel était le taux de
natalité en france avec des textes
extrêmement répressif sur la
contraception et l'avortement est non
seulement des textes répressifs mais la
façon dont ces textes étaient appliquées
alors je crois vraiment que ça n'a
absolument d'ailleurs ce que disait
démographe qui ont étudié sérieusement
la question il n'y a aucun lien et je
trouve tout à fait regrettable qui
arrive ya un problème démographique mais
je trouve tout à fait regrettable qu'on
mélange les deux questions